bien bonjour à
tous bonjour à ceux très nombreux qui
sont dans la salle et bonjour à ceux
encore plus nombreux qui sont de l'autre
côté d'Internet enfin de l'autre côté du
réseau
ou sur le réseau pour pour nous
rencontrer car comme je le rappelle à
chaque à chacune de ces
rencontres beaucoup plus nombreux sont
ceux qui sont à l'extérieur de cette
salle et qui nous suivent que à
l'intérieur je suis très heureux que
Jean que Jean-Paul bbez soit là alors
Jean-Paul betbez et moi nous partageons
quelque chose vous savez que autrefois
les guignoles avaient inventé que
j'avais une mémée à bannière de
bigor ce qui était pure je veux pas dire
calomnie
mais c'était pure invention mais vous
savez le nombre de
français et de français et de jeunes qui
ont cru qui ont qui ont mis bannière de
bigor dans mon dans mon blason était
très important mais Jean-Paul BBE lui a
une mémée à bère de bigor et même une
maman et même un papa donc voilà car est
en effet originaire des Pyrénées euh des
nôtres euh des des voilà euh vous avez
vu le snobisme hein pour eux c'est les
Hautes Pyrénées tandis que nous nous
sommes toujours réputés être des basses
Pyréné ce qui se discute extrêmement du
point de vue du relief et encore plus du
point de vue de l'altitude morale et
donc et
donc euh euh
Jean-Paul betbez est un esprit
éminent dans le monde de la science
économique puisque il est un des plus
respectés parmi les économistes français
et ça nous arrange bien parce que à
quelques nuances près chaque fois que
nous
l'entendons nous avons le sentiment un
d'être plus intelligent mais deux d'être
dans le juste parce que très souvent nos
analyses et notre vision se rencontre
alors dans son livre il fait de moi je
sais pas quoi le le le le ministre
d'État de d'un gouvernement
Moscovici on peut discuter inversé et
donc et donc ceci est une plaisanterie
que je que je prie qu'on ne retienne pas
c'était c'était juste pour lui montrer
que j'avais suivi son raisonnement voilà
donc nous sommes très très heureux que
Jean-Paul petbez Vienne partager avec
nous sa sa vision de la situation de la
France de l'Europe de l'euro et des très
grandes menac qui se multiplie je crois
au-dessus de la situation de ces
trois
institutions et
et l'idée que nous fassions à peu près
Paul une demi-heure de une demi-heure de
intervention pour vous et puis ensuite
une demi-heure ou un peu plus de
questionsréponses avec la
salle donc merci d'être là je vais
donner la parole à Robert Rochefort qui
va faire le Jean-Pierre Riou de la
journée parce que d'habitude c'est
Jean-Pierre qui qui lance l'intervenant
mais étant donné le les liens la
familiarité qui existe existe entre
Robert et et Jean-Paul betbez je lui
donne la parole et puis c'est à vous
pour une trentaine de minutes environ
oui bonjour merci François vous dire
qu'avec Jean-Paul on se connaît depuis
26 ans j'ai compté n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt qu'on a travaillé un peu
quelques mois ensemble il y a il y a 26
ans mais que c'était il y a bien
longtemps que plus récemment nous étions
membres tous les deux du Conseil
d'analyse économique auprès du Premier
ministre même si Jean-Paul l'a été plus
d'années que moi puisque moi j'en ai été
manuilitar vidé quand je suis devenu
politique élu et et députés européen non
ce que je voulais simplement vous dire
sur Jean-Paul ce que je trouve très
intéressant alors d'abord ce petit
bouquin il est passionnant parce que
souvent les livres d'économie sont
rasoirs sont un peu barbants sont un peu
doctes et ça c'est un peu écrit comme
presque comme une sorte de roman
policier euh de la politique qui est de
l'économie sauf que c'est projeté dans
l'avenir donc si vous voulez vous amuser
à essayer à la fois de de relire la
crise que dans laquelle nous sommes
rentré il y a déjà quelques années mais
également ce qui pourrait être des
scénarios comment dire des des mois et
des semestres à venir c'est tout à fait
passionnant alors évidemment Jean-Paul
il a pris un risque puisque il l'a écrit
il y a déjà probablement 3 mois ce livre
et donc ou TR il est sorti il y a 2 mois
ou de ou 3 mois donc tu l'as écrit
évidemment il y a un peu plus de mois
que ça et donc il y a déjà oui oui chez
chez Muriel chez chez plomb évidemment
euh qui est aussi d'ailleurs la
collection dans laquelle Jean-Pierre
levad est écrit ces livres cette
collection là tribune libre parce que
François Baayou lui éd dit dans des Hors
Collection dans des choses qui sont plus
mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'évidemment il a pris des risques
puisque je n'aurais pas la la taquinerie
de dire que déjà quand il parle des mois
dans lesquels nous sommes c'est pas
forcément tout à fait mais ça c'est
rigolo non ce que je voulais dire sur
sur Jean-Paul et qui est très tout à
fait intéressant c'est que bon il est il
a fait hchc il est agrégé d'économie il
a été prof à Paris 2 pendant pas toute
sa sa sa vie universitaire mais il a été
pendant très longtemps jusqu'à une
période très récente chef économiste et
chef des des services d'études
économiques d'abord du crédit Lionnais
je crois puis ensuite du du Crédit
Agricole quand il y a eu fusion ou
intégration du Crenier dans le Crédit
Agricole et ce qui est intéressant parce
que d'ailleurs c'est comme ça qu'on
s'est épisodiquement croisé
professionnellement c'est qu'il était à
un poste où il ne faisait pas que de la
macro-économie ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'il est à la fois
macroéconomiste par comment dire ce
qu'il a pu faire à la fac par ses
travaux par mais en même temps à à à la
tête du service économique du Crédit
Agricole il était celui qui donnait des
des informations et des données
économiques à toutes les caisses du
Crédit Agricole pour leur dire dans tel
secteur industriel dans la papéterie il
y a tel truc dans le tour il y a tel
truc donc ce croisement comment dire
entre la macro et la microéconomie dont
moi je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
nous manque énormément parmi nos nos
économistes comment dire que l'on entend
le plus sur les plateaux de de de de de
radio et de télévision et en particulier
la branche kénésienne de de de nos
collègues économistes dont on a parfois
le sentiment qu'ils n'ont pas dû
rencontrer une une entreprise réelle
comment dire dans le concret donc je
trouve que cette rencontre entre la
macro et la micro c'est ce qui te rend
par ailleurs comment dire outre le fait
que nous sommes d'accord sur beaucoup
d'analyses mais qui te rend complètement
en prise avec le réel et ça je je crois
qu'il fallait le souligner voilà cher
Jean-Paul merci beaucoup la parole est à
Jean-Paul bien alors mon cher vous avez
oublié un élément conjoint nous sommes
tous les deux membres de laacadémie le
Béard absolument et c'est donc la
première fois dans cette salle à mon
avis qu'il y a deux membres deacadémie
le
Bard simplement simplement je suis mond
l'Académie de B à titre étranger puisque
moi je suis bigouran et je ne suis pas B
mais voilà dire que mon père et mon
grand-père sont B absolument oui mais
mon accent est plus
fort bien bonjour à
tous une série d'éléments un petit peu
pour raconter en 2 secondes ma vie en en
un je suis professeur de faculté c'est
vrai et j'ai fini ma carrière au
panthéon du côté du côté
vivant deuxièmement j'ai fait 25 ans de
banque et j'ai décidé de de partir
plutôt prévu pour monter une boîte qui
s'appelle PP conseil avec mon épouse
parce que je j'ai le sentiment que la
crise est là et j'avais un peu le
sentiment ceci entre nous j'avais le
sentiment que quand je disais les taux
d'intérêt sont bas comme tout à l'heure
je disais et cetera on est un peu au
balcon par rapport à la dureté des temps
et à la difficulté des temps que nous
vivons et que nous vivrons et j'avais un
peu le sentiment que pour expliquer et
en même temps comprendre ce qui se passe
en disant il faut des réformes et cetera
et cetera facile à dire il faut des la
for mais plus compliqué à faire j'avais
un petit peu le sentiment de de enfin la
nécessité de de m'approcher des boîtes
donc c'est voilà ce que je suis en train
de de faire de m'approcher des boîtes
créer la mienne et 15 jours après avoir
créé ma boîte j'ai d'ailleurs eu un
papier fiscal en me disant voilà où en
est votre chiffre d'affaires et cetera
pour le moment je lu dis il est
conceptuel bon
euh quel est quelle est l'idée de ce
livre et pourquoi il est
fait pour l'idée comment est-ce que nous
les économistes on peut faire changer on
peut aider à changer ça fait des années
et des années qu'on dit il y a une crise
il y a de la dette et cetera et cetera
mais mais au fond ça ça suffit pas c'est
un peu comme un médecin qui dit vous
savez vous avez pris un peu de poids
vous faites 140 kg c'est peut-être un
peu beaucoup et les gens disent mais
mais mais c'est pas grave quand est-ce
que on peut avoir une espèce de
pédagogie économique qui fasse que cela
change avant l'arrêt cardiaque parce que
à l'arrêt cardiaque à ce momentl on dit
c'est vrai j'ai pris un peu de poids il
faudrait que je fasse attention à la
garbure au chos comme ça parce que
visiblement ça a des effets pervers et
comment nous en économie on peut d'une
certaine manière dire il faut changer il
faut s'adapter et bien entendu ça marche
c'est ça l'histoire c'estàd que oui nous
sommes dans une crise oui nous sommes
dans une mutation oui nous sommes dans
une situation extrêmement difficile oui
nous sommes au milieu du Guay au milieu
du Guay c'est-à-dire que nous savons
d'où nous venons hein c'estàd des des
des territoires et des pays qui d'une
certaine manière sont broyés par la
mondialisation sont broyés par des
changements extrêmement importants et
sont broyés par le fait que l'ordre des
forces dans le monde est en train de
changer bon donc ça c'est le vieux monde
mais mais le nouveau monde existe
c'est-à-dire le Nouveau Monde c'est dans
le livre c'est assez clair c'est
l'Europe qui nous permettrait d'exister
et de fédérer des forces de telle sorte
que dans ce nouveau monde on on
apporterait outre nos savoirs anciens
nos capacités nos histoires nos volontés
nos énergies tout ce que nous sommes et
et et le fait que nous sommes dans cette
situation intermédiaire donc en en
disant mais voilà nous d'où venons et
voilà où il faut allerous met
effectivement au milieu du gay c'est le
moment oou l'endroit où effectivement
les vents sont les les vents les
courants sont les plus les plus violents
en même temps il faut dire c'est là
qu'il faut aller et la nostalgie au sens
grec du terme c'est un retour douloureux
est effectivement difficile puisque de
l'utre côté vous avez Mélenchon qui vous
dit viens viens viens bon donc ça c'est
c'est semi appétissant si vous voulez et
de l'autre côté c'est effectivement
compliqué parce que les gens disent il y
a Angela qui nous dit viens viens viens
et donc les gens se disent mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe en réalité si on
personnifie comme ça les choses c'est
pas c'est c'est pas c'est pas juste
c'est pas correct mais mais c'est
peut-être vécu comme ça c'est peut-être
vu comme ça et c'est peut-être ressenti
comme ça et dans tout le livre pour
essayer de de comprendre et de dire ben
voilà d'abord la Nass dans laquelle nous
sommes alors Robert disait c'est vrai
que c'est un livre qui a été écrit
l'année dernière c'est vrai pour pour
l'essentiel mais mais donc la NAS donc
je fais partir mon Ty plutôt prévu et
cetera et cetera bon mais mais si on
regarde le sens de la NAS c'est c'est ça
hein c'est-à-dire que vraiment il y a un
ralentissement économique pour pas dire
réession la situation se détériore tout
simplement parce que effectivement le
monde change et que nous ne changeons
pas par rapport à ce monde et donc comme
vous changez pas par rapport à ce monde
et ben vous prenez les ajustements des
autres si les Américains décident de
baisser les taux d'intérêt à court terme
les taux d'intérêt à long terme by the
way de faire baisser le dollar si le
dollar baisse il faut bien bien qu'il a
quelque chose qui monte et c'est nous et
donc nous avons un système dans lequel
nous nous n'ayant pas nos propres
ajustements nous avons les conséquences
des ajustements des autres et et c'est
ça qui est en quelque sorte l'histoire
du livre avec l'Espagne avec la la la
Grèce qui n'a plusélectricité enfin donc
tout ceci est un peu un peu terrible
mais mais l'Espagne et cetera et avec en
particulier l'Idée et ce qui se vérifie
que l'ajustement européen c'est pas ça
que je voulais dire je voulais dire
qu'il resta une place au premier rang
pour ceux qui sont debout à
l'extérieur venez venez c'est mon côté
vieux professeur on faisait toujours
venir les gens
quiard et et donc non vous inquiétez pas
personne vous a remarqué
voilà non non
et et cette histoire si vous voulez de
euh de de l'ajustement en quelque sorte
subi que nous avons fait que
effectivement les Espagnols les Italiens
et cetera en prennent plein la tête et
en prendreont plein la tête et que
l'ajustement que nous avons est un
ajustement par la baisse des salaires
euh tout simplement parce que les taux
d'intérêt peuvent pas trop baisser j'en
peux pas trop parler de d'économie mais
enfin on en parlera après et et nous
n'avons pas une expression politique de
l'euro qui fait que il parle l'euro est
une monnaie silencieuse par contre le
dollar parle les monnaies chinoises
parlent et cetera et cetera et nous
vivons le paradoxe étonnant d'avoir une
récession et une monnaie plus forte que
les autres nos amis américains ont fait
des des papiers la semaine dernière en
disant il y a une manipulation du yen
qui a baissé plus que
nous c'est vrai qu'il y a de quoi
s'inquiéter bon mais mais eux ils sont à
3 % de croissance et nous on est à -05
l'Europe et la France pareil donc on est
bien dans une situation où quand on
subit comme on le fait à l'URE actuel on
est dans une dans une NAS après il y a
plein de chapitres là-dedans après donc
il y a toute une histoire comment les
autres font en quelque sorte des
stratégies d'ajustement par rapport à
cette crise qui qui n'est pas dans le
livre une crise financière c'est une
crise de la production c'est une crise
du changement de production et quand
quand vous voulez changer et que vous le
faites vous avez besoin du crédit ça
c'est le ce que j'appellerai le bon
crédit et quand vous ne voulez pas
changer ou pas tout de suite ou pas
encore vous avez besoin du crédit pour
gagner du temps et le crédit pour
changer ça existe c'est je sppellererai
le bon crédit et le crédit pour pour
attendre ça existe et ça sappelle la
dette et en particulier la dette
publique et et nous avons au fond dans
le monde les deux crédits le crédit pour
avancer et le crédit pour ne pas avancer
le crédit pour ne pas avancer quand il y
en a beaucoup ça inquiète tout le monde
et effectivement dans le cas qui nous
occupe ça inquiète tout le monde ce qui
fait que aux États-Unis ils se sont dit
mesdames et messieurs nous avons trop de
crédit pour ne pas avancer et donc on va
faire en sorte de réduire ce crédit pour
ne pas avancer pour développer le crédit
pour avancer ce qu'ils ont fait ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire et nous
nous avons les deux le crédit pour ne
pas avancer le crédit pour avancer et
nous avons beaucoup plus de crédit pour
ne pas avancer que de crédit pour
avancer ce qui fait que nous avançons
pas et et c'est cette histoire là alors
on peut toujours dire c'est la faute du
crédit
ou d'après moi c'est la faute du fait
que l'on ne veut pas avancer et donc
toute la l'analyse est de dire la crise
de la
finance c'est c'est en fait la crise du
dopage vous pouvez dire les banques sont
idiotes on on fait des folies et cetera
d'accord d'accord tout tout tout tout
tout ce que vous voudrait simplement sil
y avait eu des des des adaptations une
acceptation du changement les choses
vraiment n'auraient pas été pareil et le
le crédit aurait été utilisé
différemment et la conséquence aurait
été différemment différente donc il me
semble en toute hypothèse sans sans
vouloir défendre les banques qu'il faut
regarder aussi la mutation aussi le fait
que nous n'avons pas voulu changer et
aussi le fait que ce déficit que nous
avons cette dette que nous avons c'est
le c'est le prix la conséquence du fait
que nous n'avons pas voulu changer donc
je suis dans cette situation donc la
crise la crise du dopage financier est
une crise du nonchangement il y a dans
cette façon de se sortir
d'affaires un processus non coopératif
c'est-à-dire que les États-Unis sortent
les premiers du salon et les autres
prennent les portes les autres c'est
nous et cetera et cetera et comme nous
nous sommes moins en situation de
changer plus compliqué plus difficile
nous avons nos propres difficulté
évidemment antérieur plus le fait que
les autres s'ajustent et nous disent si
vous voulez avoir un EUR au fort allez-y
ça vous aidera bon après il y a des
solutions alors on dit mais comment on
se sort d'affair et dans le livre outre
que que vous avez une propomotion que
vous n'aimez pas bon parce qu'elle est
insuffisante d'accord du Premier
ministre d'accord j'ai compris j'ai
compris mais c'était une blague oui oui
ouii et il y a aussi l'idée que il y a
aussi l'idée que c'est vrai il y a aussi
aussi l'idée que Monsieur Hollande ayant
été dans de l'eau de lourde devient
changer et et et nous sauve et nous
sauve alors ça c'est également une autre
blague puisque il le com le livre
commence livre que vous allez tous
acquérir bien sûr je n fais pas un
commentaire en lieu et place de
l'acquisition donc donc Hollande dit
j'ai compris hein mon analyse n'est pas
tout à fait la bonne il faut que nous
avancions il faut que nous nous
renforcions il faut que nous changions
vous avez remarqué que que je je propose
dans le livre qui qu'il est cette
découverte épistémologique dans quelques
temps parce que sa dernière discussion
avec Monsieur Pujadas il a dit je savais
parfaitement dans quel état était la
France ce qui montre une une qualité
intellectuelle rare et
deuxièmement mais c'est plus long que
prévu he c'est un peu comme les docteurs
qui dit je savais sa maladie ça fait 3
ans que je le soigne et pour une grippe
c'est compliqué et donc il y a il y a
visiblement quelque chose qui est
problématique dans
l'histoire donc VO voilà un peu donc je
je galèe hein mais un peu ça quoi il y y
a nous avons collectivement sous-estimé
la crise sous-estimé la nature de la
crise et sousestimer les ajustements
alors bien entendu après ça c'est dans
le livre on s'est trompé dans
l'organisation de la médecine
euh quand vous faites de l'économie on a
un truc en économie qu'on appelle les
multiplicateurs
c'est un outil extrêmement sensible très
variable et en particulier il y a un
truc qui s'appelle multiplicateur fiscal
qui est un truc très compliqué c'est
comme une piqû vous vous approchez vous
dire je vais vous piquer et avant même
d'être piqué vous avez
réagi nos hommes politiques qui ont une
conception une connaissance de
l'économie pratique qui est en devenenir
hein en devenir et de l'entreprise qui
est également en début n'ont pas compris
que la la la fiscalité à l'entreprise
c'est pas un un tir à la cible fixe on
dit bougez pas je vais vous
fiscaliser dès qu'on vous dit je vais
vous je vais vous fiscaliser vous allez
bouger c'est les palambes on dit pas
bougez pas je vais vous tirer dessus ça
existe pas ça et pour les entreprises
c'est évidemment très rapide et pour les
ménages ça commence à bouger aussi et ce
qui s'est passé si vous voulez c'est que
l'on dit tiens je crois qu'on va on va
fiscaliser un peu les riches et Cera et
cetera bon d'accordon qu'est-ce que
c'est qui quelqu'un qui est riche c'est
quelqu'un qui gagne plus que
moi bon mais ça fait plein de gens hein
et et donc les gens ont eu une
incertitude là-dessus on disant est-ce
que je vais pas être donc il y a eu un
processus d'inquiétude et en septembre
dernier je vais pas être trop long
là-dessus vous me dites en septembre
dernier il y a eu une erreur que nous
payons encore à la suite si vous voulez
la fiscalité Sarkozi et cetera mais tout
d'accord sur la fiscalité en en en sous
estimant la gravité de la crise en en
pensant qu'on repartirait et en disant
faisons le le salale boulot d'abord à
savoir la fiscalité et on fera le boulot
compliqué ensuite avec les réformes donc
on aura du certainère gagneré du temps
on aura montré à l'Europe qu'on arrive à
réduire déficit budgétaire et on
travaillera dans le dur après c'est une
erreur
totale totale d'abord parce que tout le
pays est ttanisé dès lors que vous
approchez avec les petites pincettes
premier point et vous voyez à l'heure
actuelle à quel point les entrepreneurs
ont arrêté de stocker ont arrêté
d'investir l'année dernière la France a
perdu 1 % sur la diminution des
stocks vous approchez vous dites je vais
faire quelque chose bon d'accord
j'arrête de stocker j'arrête d'investir
et j'arrête évidemment d'embaucher et
c'est pour ça que que et vous n'avez
encore rien
fait
bon l'économie c'est la gestion des
anticipations vous envoyez des messages
vous avez tiré avant d'avoir pressé sur
la cachette dans les têtes des gens et
et et ceci dans la situation hyper
réactive dans laquelle nous sommes et
donc aujourd'hui on est dans cette dans
cette crise hein dans laquelle on dit
mais comment on va se sortir d'affaires
donc c'est celle c'est celle du livre
comment on va avancer comment on va
faire des réformes comment on va passer
en quelque sorte de la tétanie dans
laquelle les gens vivent les personnes
vivent les entreprises vivent pour pour
avancer et et dire on va avoir peu plus
de croissance alors vous avvez vu la
semaine dernière que Monsieur Moscovici
Premier ministre en chapitre 12
euh je sais c'est à réécrire euh
euh a fait des fait des des propositions
ça Mar ça marche pas ça marche pas et ça
peut pas marcher tout simplement parce
que la thérapie euh n'a pas été la bonne
bon il y a une deuxième chose je v pas
être trop long mais sur sur Galois
normalement il aurait fallu faire Galois
d'abord et puis la fiscalité ensuite
hein du style on va aider les
entreprises et puis après on va comm ça
et ensuite mais simplement on a fait
l'inverse et on a on a donc
utilisé la fiscalité pour des raisons
politiques à mon avis et puis quand on a
tétanisé on dit bon Dieu de Bon Dieu on
a un problème de compétitivité et à ce
momentlà l'économie était déjà réduite
et à ce moment-là on utilisit Galois la
moitié d'un Galois un demi-galois mais
mais mais comment vous faites avec un
demi Galois étant entendu que vous
pouvez pas faire une déduction up front
sur les salaires on dit je vais
fabriquer un cice et dans un an les gens
seront remboursés avec en plus dans
l'état des dans l'état d'esprit que les
gens ont dès lors qu'ils arriveront avec
un cice ils auront droit à une
vérification fiscale donc vous voyez
bien à quel point on a un mécanisme qui
est qui est compliqué qui est compliqué
euh personne n'a rien contre contre
contre offentivement Gallois au
contraire mais vous vous rappelez à quel
point euh vous vous disiez la France
n'est pas un pays économique quoi ça
c'est clair hein il y a eu des mois et
des mois on a dit mesdames et messieurs
il y a deux types de compétitivité tu as
vu la compétitivité coût et la
compétitivité hors coût et le Premier
ministre actuel a dit ceux qui croient
que la compétitivité a lieu en lien avec
les salaires n'ont rien compris ce qui
est quand même une grande phrase hein
euh alors que que la France a un
problème de compétitivité coû euh est en
perte de en perte depuis plusieurs
années
de de marché sur des activités éit de
milieu de
gamme quand vous achetez une Porsche
effectivement vous allez pas négocier
trop sur les salaires sur les prix bon
prior mais sur des voitures de milieu de
gamme sur des produits de milieu de
gamme les coûts c'est extrêmement
importants et quand vous avez comme le
cas français des salaires élevés pour
des milieux de gamme évidemment vous
prenez tout plein pot donc c'est c'est
bien ça mais vous voyez bien à quel
point ça a été très difficile
d'accoucher ça alors je j'arrête là donc
après avoir découvert ça ben il faut se
sortir d'affaire on découvre qu'il faut
se rapprocher de l'Allemagne mais il
faut se rapprocher de l'Allemagne à
notre manière donc il y a un livre il y
a tout un chapitre où je parle Monsieur
Hollande voulant se rapprocher de
l'Allemagne a décidé d'avoir un groupe
secret et je vais je livre ces travaux
bien entendu c'est moi qui l' écrit ça
me pose pas de problème donc et voilà
étant entendu qu'on peut pas se
rapprocher de l'Allemagne en étant
contre comme comme l'Allemagne d'abord
c'est pas possible he et donc on est
battu voyez donc on a tout un problème
en quelque sorte de de compréhension de
notre réalité et le livre c'est celui-là
c'est sachant qui nous sommes sachant
quel est notre notre système économique
pourquoi on a des PME dans dans les
territoires qu'on connait qui sont
petites Pitchoun qui sont qui sont to je
traduirai
après donc qui sont qui sont visant en
taille pourquoi est-ce qu'elles ne
veulent pas avancer pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles ne veulent pas mordre et cetera
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on a ça on peut
toujours rêver sur le melstant
allementand on l'a pas hein on a des
entreprises qui sont deux fois plus
petites à trois fois plus petites et qui
vivent deux fois plus deux fois moins
longtemps tout simplement parce qu'elle
se venteent donc pour quelle raison
avons-nous cette faiblesse la deuxième
chose qui est extrêmement importante me
semble-t-il et là je pense que c'est
quelque chose que nous qui qui sont les
problèmes des
territoires j'ai le sentiment si vous
voulez que la la la solution française
c'est de la PME des territoires bon la
PME la faire vivre se développer en
liaison avec des territoires en liaison
en unisson avec des territoires dans des
dans des dans des endroits où elles
seraient plus comprises plus
accepté o elle vivrait mieux elle serait
pas l'ennemi
l'exploiteur bon tous ces trucs là et et
et cette cette cette ce lien PME
territoire me semble-t-il est quelque
chose d'extrêmement puissant mais bien
entendu il faut qu'il ait de l'espace et
pour avoir la la solution en quelque
sorte PME territoire il faut que vous
ayez de la flexibilité et cetera pour de
la croissance pas de la flexibilité pour
la flexibilité et à côté de ça et c'est
là qu'il y a la nécessité aussi d'avoir
des réformes publiques pour réduire la
dépense publique donc je finis la
solution que je propose si vous voulez
par rapport à ça et que le président va
mettre en place il m'a renvoyé une
lettre en plus làdessus mais c'est pas
pour ça
qu' sur le même pas sur le choix de la
politique parceil' dit qu'il était avait
raison
mais sur la politique me semble-t-il
c'est un du point de vue de la dépense
publique la contraindre mais pas la
contraindre immédiatement la contrainte
le temps pour moderniser l'état je pense
que la mod de l'État c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important pour donner des
marges de manœuvre pour la dynamisation
privée et donc l'idée du livre c'est
s'il nous arrivit demain que l'on
modernise l'État et que l'on fasse vivre
les PME et les territoires dans une
France plus européenne on vivrait mieux
merci alors il doit y avoir un micro qui
est disponible se promène euh c'était
parfait
même on a vous avez montrer que la
concision pouvait être une vertu
pyrénéenne et donc et donc toutes les
questions sont ouvertes sur la situation
économique du pays sur la stratégie
envisageable pour apporter les réponses
qui s'imposent sur la gravité des choses
sur tout ça est ouvert de Europe euro
France tout ça économie tout ça est
ouvert il y a une seule règle c'est
alternance masculin féminin dans les
questions et donc tu tu es chargé de
veiller à cette alternance qui veut
poser la première question
oui on peut prendre deux ou trois
question à la suite voilà oui bonjour
monsieur bber merci beaucoup pour cette
intervention passionnante euh au niveau
des combinaisons microéconomie
macroéconomie on peut voir quand même
les les différentes politiques qui sont
menées actuellement pour résorber la
crise j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu
un mix entre des politiques monétaires
accommodantes et des politiques de
rigueur avec un mélange entre les deux
et faisant que je dirais une fois tous
les 15 jours on dit ne fait-on pas trop
dans la rigur une fois tous les 15 jours
on dit ne fait-on pas trop dans la
politique monétaire accommodante avec
des risques d'inflation mais au niveau
des choix de politique est-ce qu'il n'y
a pas une troisième qui est un peu
oubliée c'est une politique qui viserait
à faire diminuer le prix des actifs
réels car si l' regarde au niveau
mondial on a une reprise aux États-Unis
qui fait suite à une baisse de 50 % de
l'immobilier c'est un peu la même chose
en Irlande en Allemagne il n'y a pas de
baisse des actifs réels mais finalement
leur hausse a été maîtrisé et on voit
qu'ils ont eu par rapport à nous un
avantage compétitif si on regarde ce qui
se passe en Espagne finalement là on a
une politique je a compris nous c'est
pas sûr mais lui a
compris donc première question deuxè
question
féminine là-bas en haut euh à gauche de
l'hémicycle pas tout à fait en cohérence
avec ce qui vient d'être dit mais euh
simplement praticopratique demain les
haut fourneaux de Florange en laorine
vont s'arrêter définitivement or en même
temps il y a des bruits qui courent que
le gaz de charbon le célèbre
anciennement terrifiant grisou est une
matière première qui peut
réindustrialiser cette région française
ce territoire français alors qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de de ça de ce phénomène
là qui est-ce qui a ou devrait avoir
l'initiative de chercher si c'est une
solution merci masculine masculine la
question derrière toute analyse il y a
une part de théorie vous avez fait
allusion tout à
l'heure au multiplicateur
fiscal que pensez-vous de l'erreur
commise par le FMI qui a été révélé il y
a pas si longtemps que ça par la pre par
la presse sur cette erreur là ces
conséquences d'autant plus que d'autres
erreurs ont été révélées également dans
la presse notamment sur une allégation
de Mario Dragui devant le Conseil
européen et une der nire celle du de
l'économiste américain Kennet trogof qui
avait lui aussi commis une même deux
erreurs dans une théorie qui n'a pas été
sans influence dans les politiques
gouvernementales merci
féminin
lab
excuse-mo j'avais une question sur les
distorsions de concurrence en Europe et
notamment fiscale parce que ça fait plus
de 10 ans qu'on parle de ces questions
là que la crise forcément amplifie les
distorsions de concurrence fiscale et
que finalement je pas ce que vous en
pensez ce de ce
point qure questions merci vous devriez
prévenir que vous nrez pas rentrez pas
chez vous ce soir
hein tout j'ai pas voulu être trop rude
en réduisant mais je comprenais et puis
en plus comme j'étais en un peu en
désaccord à la suite de votre
débat micro macro accommodement et
cetera premier point je n'ai rien contre
la
rigueur c'est que personne n parce que
utiliser de manière rigoureuse l'argent
public c'est respecter profondément
l'argent gagné par le public d'accord
donc je je vois pas pourquoi on serait
je je parle à mon mon nomin hostile à la
rigueur il faut pas avoir peur de cela
ça s'appelle l'efficacité ça s'appelle
en morale le respect du travail et le
respect de l'effort des gens le problème
c'est évidemment comment je dose ça et
comment je dose ça aujourd'hui est dans
le temps c'est tout le problème des
perspectives si je vous dis mesdames et
messieurs
devant vous il y a moins de croissance
encore plus et dans 10 ans et dans 20
ans ça sera terrifiant vous êtes
titanisé et vous dites j'arrête d'une
certaine manière c'est ce qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle c'est pour ça qu'il
faut trouver un mécanisme qui soit à la
fois rigoureux dans la façon de gérer et
rigoureux dans la façon de de dynamiser
les deux éléments sont extrêmement la
rigueur est un est une composante de la
solution mais la solution a deux phases
cette pH c'est un la la modernisation
publique dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
le fait par exemple le système public
les universitaire et cetera je trouve
que j'en suis un peuvent fonctionner
davantage et cetera et cetera que les
écoles peuvent changer ça je crois que
vous connaissez et être plus efficace
tout ceci est possible moderniser en
liaison avec nouvell technologie et
fondamentalement que les PME les
territoires doivent être mises sous
tension sous tension productive
dynamique et que ceci nous permet de de
de som vous parliz de deux risques après
je peux être trop long sur le risque
d'inflation et le risque de déflation le
risque d'inflation faites attention il
fait partie pour une part de la solution
et quand vous regardez ce qui oui oui
oui il faut être des grands garçons à
l'heure actuelle les politiques
monétaires ce sont des politiques
monétaires concurrentielle extrêmement
violente quand vous avez monsieur Bern
qui est
remarcablement intelligent il est à la
fois professeur de faculté et
profondément américain les deux et la
façon dont il vous dont il envoie les
deux messages du style c'est
techniquement juste et c'est
techniquement quelque chose qui
m'arrange est très bon ne et nous
n'avons pas sauf dragi et sauf que à
l'heure actuelle des gens de cette de
cette envergure dans le débat mondial
donc les solutions américaines théorique
sont des solutions qui les arrangent ce
qui fait que pour le moment les taux
d'intérêt américains à court terme sont
à zéro et quelques les taux d'intérêt à
long terme américains sont à 17 et
l'inflation est à
2 et donc aujourd'hui tous les taux
d'intérêt américains sont négatifs en
termes
réel vous êtes en
Angleterre on vous dit notre objectif
d'inflation est de 2 % manque de chance
l'inflation qu'on a est à
33 vous allez pas
m'embêter ce qui fait que la diminution
de la valeur réelle des de la dette se
met en place elle est accompagnée et
c'est ça qui est la partie de la
solution elle est accompagnée par la
baisse de la
devise et je peux vous dire un secret la
livre sterling est accrochée au
dollar mais mais ça fait partie du
système c'est un système de grandes
personnes donc il fonctionne de manière
un peu dual en disant c'est parfait et
puis et puis et ça marche il y a 15
jours 3 il a non il y a 2 mois vous avez
la politique monétaire japonaise le
Premier ministre arrive et dit on va
faire quelque chose et on va créer de la
monnaie comme jamais vous allez voir ce
que vous allez voir B
d'accord l'inflation ils sont en
déflation ils passent donc ils sont à
mo-s 0 et quelques et les prévisions
c'est qu'en 2014 ils seront 3 ils auront
3 %
d'inflation donc c'est un choc énorme au
tout début les Américains disent vous
êtes fous qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
vous êtes fou ça veut dire vous en
faites plus que nous en
français et au tout début ça a été
moyennement
prix et puis maintenant ça y est on dit
c'est pas mal ton ton truc
c'est assez étonnant ce qui s'est passé
ça ça date et si vous regz le fin cette
semaine et particulier cette matin vous
verrez comment ça c'est il y a un
revirement qui se met en place et ce
revirement se met en place mais la
banque la banque centrale européenne ne
le fait pas donc il y a à l'heure
actuelle une politique si vous voulez
pro inflation qui se met en place dans
le temps et cetera je sur la façon de
fonctionner pour pas angoisser mais mais
ça participe de la solution je ne suis
pas pr
inflation mais si vous avez l'inflation
autour de 2 à 3 % ça participe la
solution en revanche je suis contre
votre solution de la déflation quand
vous dites j'ai une
idée c'est une idée on va faire baisser
le prix de l'immobilier c'est une
excellente idée d'ailleurs puisque c'est
celle du gouvernement actuel c'est une
excellente idée virgule
catastrophique quand vous dites mesdames
et messieurs J'ai une idée vous les
Français 40 % de votre valeur de votre
patrimoine c'est de l'immobilier et ben
faire baisser la valeur bon comme ça ça
aidera ceux qui n'ont pas de de maison à
acquérir une maison quelles sont les
maisons les moins chères de France ce
sont celles qui sont déclarées par les
ministres je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué
bon je n'aurais pas dû dire des choses
de cette nature
mais comme je ne fais pas de politique
c'est
euh et a priori ça va continuer
euh je je je je crois qu'il faut faire
très attention à ça si vous mettez dans
l'état d'esprit des
gens que le que les prix de l'immobilier
vont
baisser vous voulez tétaniser nous
sommes à Paris à Paris le prix de
l'immobilier moyen c'est 8000 € le mètre
carré alleer à bannière de Biger à banè
du Biger pour 8000 m pour 8000 € vous en
avez plein de mètres Carr
vous avez tout ce que vous voulez les
prix de mil000immobilier sont en train
de baisser dans le système dans le en
dehors de Paris en dehors de trois ou
quatre grandes villes et c'est en train
de s'ajuster mais très violemment ça
n'est pas mal que ça s'ajuste si vous
voulez mais mais il faut il faut que ça
s'ajuste en quelque sorte normalement et
la bonne façon d'ajuster c'est de
construire si vous dites mesdames et
messieurs J'ai trouvé une solution on va
faire baisser le prix
immobilier vous tétanisez les gens qui
ont des maisons et vous n' n'allez
n'allez pas aider ceux qui voudraient
acquérir ce pour une bonne raison c'est
qu'ils n'uront pas le
pognon si vous construisez et vous avez
une politique de construction et de
développement de la construction à ce
moment-là vous réduisez les coûts de la
construction puisque vous avez entre
parenthèses ce qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement est très bon là leur
actuelle sur les normes et cetera ça ça
ça ça ça c'est bien mais
fondamentalement il faut en quelque
sorte sorte faire baisser bien les
prix voz donc par rapport à votre
politique je résume ma réponse étit trop
longue un de la rigueur il en faut la
rigueur c'est la façon de gérer l'argent
public pour le moderniser et la rigueur
c'est la façon d'organiser le système
privé l'inflation il en aura un peu mais
il faut faire très attention à ce que ce
soit pas la solution des autres et notre
problème à nous et la la gestion des
prix d'actif faut faire très attention à
ça parce que les pr les pays dont vous
avez m'avez parlé qui ont tu en Espagne
et cetera ce sont eux qui ont tu une
bulle
ok mais nous n'avons pas eu de bulles
c'est que grosse on a un prix de
l'immobilier qui est élevé mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils ont eu une bulle en
Espagne et Cera et cetera parce que ça a
été une bulle qui a été faite avec du
crédit et ils ont fait du crédit au
logement alors que nous on fait en
France du crédit à la personne peut-être
qu'on en a fait un peu beaucoup coup
peut-être qu'il y a eu des trucs mais où
est-ce que c'est les où sont les
endroits fragiles dans l'immobilier
français ils sont quand vous avez un
couple qui est endetté sur 25 ans au
limite de sa capacité de remboursement
25 ans en France maintenant c'est cinq
divorces
ok on a passé à des accidents de la vie
en en système bancaire et donc vous
aveit fragilisé les populations mais
ceci n'a rien à voir avec ce qui s'est
passé en Espagne rien ce qui s'est passé
en Italie rien qui un peu et surtout
donc on a eu une montée des prix mais
cette montée des prix techniquement n'a
pas la même la même effet si vous voulez
et si aujourd'hui vous avez la solution
espagnole pour gérer notre problème à
nous je je pense que c'est pas une bonne
bonne idée voilà mon sentiment je suis
trop long deuxièmement gaz de schiste
Florange alleer en chercher allez en
chercher le principe de
précaution est un principe qui du point
de vue théorique est vrai mais le
principe de précaution c'est dans le
doute
agit dans le c'est ça l'histoire du
principe quand vous quand on lit les
textes c'est pas dans ce livre là mais
j'avais regardé qui a été l'auteur du
principe de précaution c'était des
scientifiques et et et c'est dans c'est
l'incertitude donc dans dans les
phénomènes d'incertitude je prends
évidemment des des mesure mais j'agis si
dans le principe de précaution je n'agis
pas à ce moment-là je me mets dans une
situation terrifiante donc allez
chercher votre gaz de schiste vous savez
bien que il a été décidé en France que
nous allons le gaz de oui mais allez
chercher aussi allez chercher aussi le
gaz de schiste vous savez que dans les
décdé française il a été décidé de le
garder pour le prochain ququena
euh ça il peut se garder longtemps si
nous ne prenons pas de risque nous ne
ferons rien et la prise de risque
rationnelle ça s'appelle le principe de
précaution oui mais ma question était
surtout qui qui est ce jeu quand vous
dites jeu euh ce n'est pas vous
personnellement qui est-ce qui doit
prendre le
risquetat des des qui ce sont des
entrepreneurs ce sont des entrepreneurs
et si c'est des des éléments risqués il
faut qu'il y ait de l'argent de l'argent
public comment dans leadre d'une
législation mais oui mais législation si
vous si on veut mourir bon il y a aucun
problème là-dessus hein sur la tétanie
l'utanasis ça existe c'est du grec bon
c'est une façon on peut mais si nous
voulons avoir plus de croissance
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les américains ils
ont baissé le taux d'intérêt à court
terme baisser taux d'intérêt à long
terme baisser les salaires baisser le
dollar baisser le prix de
l'énergie qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
Français les taux d'intérêt à court
terme pas vraiment les taux d'intérêt à
long terme ça commence le le dollar pas
l'euro pas vraiment le salaire pas
encore et le prix de l'énergie il
monte si nous ne voulons pas avoir un
justement qui porte fondamentalement sur
les salaires il faudra qu'on a d'autres
choses mais en économie l'économie j'y
crois beaucoup vous aimez ou vous aimez
pas mais ça s'applique et donc ou bien
vous AZ avez des techniques qui
fonctionn avec les logiques économiques
et qui les accommodent et qui les
comprennent et qui les font passer ou
bien vous dites non mesdames et
messieurs c'est de l'économie et moi je
va faire la politique et ben l'économie
se venge l'économie se venge
voilà mon histoire donc moi je suis très
favorable à
l'exploration il y a des risques il y a
des difficultés il y a des problèmes et
bien sûr sur les
multiplicateurs il y a eu des erreurs
d'accord celui qui n'a pas fait des reur
dans sa vie me
dit
voilà voilà la première
donc
R et et cetera on fait on commis des
erreurs et cetera et cetera simplement
j'ai passé mon weekend là-dessus en
liaison avec la façon le déchaînement
qu'il a eu derrière donc il y a eu des
travaux qui ont été faits et et j'ai lu
le texte d'origine c'est un texte
scientifique technique on a parlé tout à
l'heure en France on naurait pas fait
ça la culture américaine c'est qu'ils
ont pris 20 et quelques pays ils ont
pris toute une série de cas ils ont
travaillé sur 2500 variables bon
d'accord et ces 2500 variables on trouve
ils ont trouvé que quand vous avez un
ratio dette sur PIB de plus de 90 % vous
avez une chute de votre production donc
la nouveauté ça a été ça ça a été cette
chute alors il y a eu deux choses
un il y a eu des travaux qui ont été
revu en cause remis en cause sur ce ce
problème de 90 % et de et de ure et la
deuxième chose ça qui leur
responsabilité il leur dit c'est dans le
F time il y avait un problème c'est pas
un problème d'Excel c'est un problème de
powerp c'est un problème c'est que que
pour pour simplifier votre message vous
devez dire des trucs qui sont trop
simples et alors ils ont dit à partir de
90 % tu es mort ce qui est pas vrai
puisque nos amis japonais sont morts si
vous voulez mais ils sont pas au courant
hein euh et et donc il y en a toute une
série de gens parisqu'ils ont un ratio
de 2 et demi eux
donc ils sont morts depuis longtemps
mais il continuent
d'exister donc mais ce qui se passe et
d'autres travaux sont sortis en
particulier de la Banque centrale
européenne je vous renvoie au travaux de
la Banque centrale européenne dans le
Bulletin de mars la Banque centrale
européenne qui sont sortis là-dessus il
se trouve
que à Paris on critique les livres et en
province on les
lit bon moi mon côté province c'est que
je lis les textes bon et mant je d ah
c'est c'est une horreur d'accord
d'accord c'est une horreur ils se sont
trompés c'est vrai mais les textes
d'origine sont pas tout à fait comme ça
et la la position de la Banque centrale
européenne n'est pas tout à fait comme
ça et aucun des spécialistes européens n
dit à partir de 90 % tu es
mort simplement la bourrasque est-elle
que quand vous écoutez monsieur Barroso
ce qui m'arrive un peu mais moins que
d'autres il a dit on est allé trop vite
et cetera et cetera et c'est
effectivement il y a eu un moment donné
que le le soutien en quelque sorte
idéologique qui était porté par ces
travaux de rogof éta était tel que ça
les a aidé en disant il faut faire ça
parce qu' on va mourir donc ils sont en
train en quelque sorte de revenir en
arrière mon idée est simple il faut
donner du temps au temps hein et il faut
moderniser et bien entendu dans le temps
personne ne va réduire la dépense
publique immédiatement ou alors là vous
mettez le pays en en en dépression sur
la même et et la façon mais le problème
politique est de dire nous allons nous
mettre dans une situation sur 5 ans par
exemple de d'assaainissement et
d'amélioration la la politique de rogof
a été de mettre l'accent sur un chiffre
sur une falaise cette falaise n'existe
pas en tant que telle en en toute
hypothèse le seuil du style nous avons
trop de dette publique lui existe euh
sur la la concurrence fiscale bien sûr
simplement quand vous regardez mais je
suis mon spécialiste que la la
construction européenne et cetera et
cetera tout n'a pas été fait tout n'a
pas été écrit d'une certaine manière il
y avait aussi l'idée du mouvement que le
mouvement d'une certaine manière nous
aiderait à à
avancer sur les problèmes de concurrence
fiscale vous savez de M je pas dire de
bêtises mais les les phénomènes de de
fiscalité sont de sont nation
sont nationaux et donc chacun est
responsable est responsable et la TVA
pour des raison assez particulière
est-elle d'intérêt plus plus commun on
peut discuter pourquoi mais et donc on a
on a essayé de fabriquer la construction
européenne avec des éléments
hétérogènes ça c'est clair il y a toute
une série d'autres hétérogénéités par
exemple domaine militaire et autres et
on se dit maintenant qu'il faut essayer
de
réduire comment on peut réduire ça d'une
manière d'une manière à mon avis
correcte a avec le avec le Parlement
européen avec les lois sur la problèmes
de concurrence avec peu à peu l'idée de
réduire les écarts les écarts pour faire
en sorte que la concurrence fiscale
n'est pas lieu parce que si vous avez
vous la concurrence fiscale
euh il y avait l'idée que la concurrence
fiscale a les petits et que les gros euh
ne sen rendrai pas compte OK
ok simplement quand les gros deviennent
moins gros et que les petits deviennent
plus plus plus plantureux à l'ône du
fait
que voilà le problème que j'ai et quand
vous avez l'Irlande qui se développe
parce qu'elle est toute pauvre au 19e
siècle et ce et cetera et que grâce à ça
elle fabrique une bulle vous avez une
catastrophe qui se met en place donc
effectivement quand vous n'êtes pas
rigoureux vous le payez toujours la
concurrence fiscale est contradictoire
avec la construction européenne après
moi merci beaucoup je vais je vais
redonner les
questions si je peux mettre un grain de
sel gran Salice mais tout petit enfin je
crois
essentiel on est en train de retomber en
plein dans la faiblesse
française depuis des
mois et cette faiblesse française pour
moi elle est très simple
c'est qu'on croit qu'il existe une
baguette magique pour éviter de faire le
travail ah
alors la baguette magique au moi j'en ai
connu plein d'ailleurs toujours des
esprits du même ordre ceux qui disent au
fond pour faire le travail c'est très
simple il faut que
l'inflation reparte on n'ura pas à payer
de la dette je dis oui très bien il y a
une part euh faut pas être sorti de
Polytechnique pour comprendre que si
vous avez devant vous la perspective que
les prix vont baisser vous allez
attendre pour acheter si vous avez la
perspective que les prix vont augmenter
vous allez acheter tout de suite pour ne
pas avoir à payer plus cher c'est moi
moi je suis pas docteur en économie mais
j'arrive à comprendre ce genre de choses
très bien donc il faut hein voilà et
c'est mieux
si si on veut investir que grosso modo
les taux
soient à peu près aligné sur croissance
plus inflation c'est des choses de
j'arrive j'arrive à comprendre ce genre
de choses bon mais c'est pas ce que je
veux
dire autre baguette magique il faut
désormais se remettre à la dépense
publique de toutes nos
forces j'ai vu alors je vais parler à
voix basse j'ai vu des responsables
politiques d'extrême gauche beaucoup qui
disent il faut mettre d'urgence un terme
à
l'austérité j'ai vu des responsable j'ai
vu des responsables du centre dire la
décision la plus urgente c'est de d'en
finir avec l'austérité mes chers amis on
n'a pas commencé l'austérité
n'est-ce pas on vit avec l'idée
mythique que ça y est on est en train de
s'aligner sur 3 % de déficit par rapport
au PIB ce qui signifie au moins 6 % de
déficit par rapport à la dépense
publique française ce qui signifie au
moins 15 % de déficit par rapport au
budget de l'État si on le rapporte au
budget de l'État ou 17 ou 20 bon mais le
le le on n à 3 % on est à 5 % de déficit
en 2012 allez
4,8 ou 9 bon de quoi on
parle alors je sais que à cause de cette
histoire de de d'un chiffre mal placé
dans le powerp de de vos intellectuels
américains économistes américains on est
en train d'expliquer qu'on s'est
trompé en disant qu'il fallait limiter
le recours à la dette mes chers amis
c'est très simple l'autre jour madelein
qui est un type que j'estime beaucoup en
dehors des différences que nous avons
sur la pensée je lui ai dit un jour en
réunion de bureau toi et moi on est
d'accord sur tout sauf sur l'homme et la
société ça
fait ça fait pas mal mais c'est un type
intelligent et qui comprend un certain
nombre de choses dont je parle avec lui
il m'envoie un sms désespéré à 11h du
soir il dit je suis devant comment
s'appelle l'émission CD non pass céd
dans
l'air l'émission du soir M croisé je
sais pas quoi il dit tous les experts
qui sont là expliquent qu'il faut que on
s'est trompé sur la dette et que tout ce
qu'on a dit de mal dette était faux je
lui ai répondu toujours par SMS
explique-leur que la solution est
maintenant qu'il faut emprunter à fond
n'est-ce pas quand vous êtes un ménage
surendetté non mais c'était ironique
monsieur n'applaudissez pas je
disais donc le le le l'idée que quand
vous avez un budget de l'État pour
assurer le service de la dette qui est
devenu de très loin le premier budget de
la Nation alors que vous avez des taux
d'intérêt bas si vous décidez que vous
allez faire exploser ce budget ne vous
étonnez pas de ne pas avoir d'argent
pour autre chose ne vous étonnez pas
d'être obligé d'augmenter les impôts ne
vous étonnez pas de ne pas avoir de quoi
assurer des services public sérieux
enfin on a l'impression que c'est un
pays qui remplace le bon sens par de la
théorie déconnante excusez-moi je je
parle comme comme on devrait pas voilà
moi je pense qu'il faut avoir des idées
simples j'en ai une idée simple la crise
ne vient pas
d'ailleurs tous ceux qui pensent que la
crise vient
des États-Unis du Japon de la Chine de
l'euro de l'Europe de tout ça bon il y a
des facteurs aggravants la crise vient
de chez nous c'est pas l'Allemagne qui
empêche que nous apprenions à lire à nos
enfants c'est un facteur
extraordinairement puissant de de de
notre de nos difficultés national de
l'adaptation de notre de notre force de
travail c'est
pas c'est pas raison de nos voisins que
nous avons laissé tomber un certain que
nous nous sommes trompés dans la gamme
des
automobiles c'est pas les Allemands qui
nous ont forcé à nous tromper dans la
gamme des automobiles et à fabriquer des
automobiles basses et moyen GAM c'est
pas la faute des autres si nous n'avons
pas de stratégie dans des domaines
absolument essentiels c'est d'ailleurs
pas de stratégie du tout c'est pas de la
faute des autres si nous avons une vie
politique déconsidér
soupçonné de corruption ou de fraude à
chaque instant et ça participe à la
confiance du pays c'est nos problèmes
que nous ne voulons pas traiter alors on
va chercher des prétextes ailleurs en
expliquant que un jour on va avoir la
baguette magique pour changer tout ça
nous ne la trouverons la baguette
magique que quand nous nous mettrons au
boulot nous-mêmes en considérant que
d'accord l'euro est probablement trop
mais enfin comme autour de nous il y a
aucun pays qui a une balance commerciale
effondre du même genre une balance
commerciale effondrée comme la nôtre
c'est quand même pas de la faute de
l'euro puisque les autres réussiss à
exporter et si demain on a une monnaie
faible pour un pays qui est en déficit
de balance commerciale ça va s'améliorer
ou s'agrave bon sang de bois vous allez
devoir payer plus cher ce que vous
achetez bon vous voyez bien qu'il y a
quand même une mobilisation des esprits
au fond de Gaulle qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
en 58 moi je pense qu'on est exactement
à ce ce point d'inflexion là on était
dans un pays qui
était déconsidéré et désespéré parce
qu'il n'arrivait pas à ressaisir les
forces nationales et ben il les a
ressaisis
oh il a il a peut-être pas tout fait
bien enfin tout d'un coup la situation
psychologique du pays s'est améliorée et
la situation psychologique du pays est
un facteur essentiel du ressaisissement
du pays c'est ça qu'il faut faire et pas
chercher ailleurs les raisons de nos
elles sont chez
nous on passe on passe à une autre série
qui sera la dernière série oui je vais
être extrêmement
bref nous savons qu' en France on est
assez assez d'accord sur le reste sur
tout ce et moi également je suis voilà
vous vous n'avez pas parlé vous avez
parlé de façon indirect de la TR de la
marge des entreprises nous savons qu'en
France n avons un problème de marge des
entreprises qui qui handicape notre
investissement mais il y a des capitaux
qui pourraient servir à l'investissement
qui sont disponibles qui sont entreposés
sous forme de lignes comptbl dans les
paradis fiscaux vous avez beaucoup
travaillé pour les banques qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de la position des banques
françaises par rapport aux paradis
fiscaux et pensez-vous que l'instrument
du secret bancaire qui a été choisi
récemment soit le bon pour mettre fin à
cette anomalie et rapatrier les capitaux
féminin
la prochaine fois vous demanderez plutôt
des questions
faciles
féminin bonsoir bonsoir madame donc la
France je pense que la France est un
beau pays où il fait bon vivre où les
gens font des enfants c'est quand même
des
indicateurs favorables et on ne
noircissont pas trop le tableau euh vous
avez donc parler de moderniser le pays
est-ce moderniser moderniser l'état
l'organisationorganisation de l'État
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas décliner aussi
la qualité de la vie le bonheur et bon
ça va peut-être vous faire bondir mais
pourquoi ne pas aller jusqu'à diminuer
le temps de travail les Anglais le font
et je peux
mex ce serait aussi une peut-être
solution pour le problème du chômage je
voudrais avoir votre avis là-dessus
est-ce que
éventuellement aussi également une main
d'œuvre vous avez parlé donc de
moderniser oui
euh des grands travaux on peut en
envisager au niveau de du de l'Urban de
l'urbanisme on pourrait faire beaucoup
de très jolies choses pour aménager nos
ville avec une main d'œuvre peut-être
vous avez parlé du coût du travail
également
est-ce qu'on pourrait en droit du
travail faire appel à une main d'œuvre
sur la base du volontariat bien sûr qui
est actuellement sans emploi et qui
pourrait
éventuellement être mise à disposition
des des villes enfin c'est toute une
politique à revoir c'est donc une
réflexion j'aimerais qu'on la qu'on la
soulève et qu'on en parle c'est à à vous
allez-ys généux non madame monsieur s'il
vous
plaît un monsieur
là merci vous avez souligné le
l'importance du prix de l'énergie dans
la compétitivité et Monsieur berou
parler de la commerce Baayou excusez-moi
ou là là
désolé vous comprenez pourquoi je
l'invite je je suis pas je suis pas des
Pyréné désolé il y a il y a des non mais
allez et vous parliez de balance
commerciale qui est me semble-t-il
grandement déficitaire uniquement à
cause des importations de pétrole est-ce
qu'on a des uniqu enfin à 80 % 69
milliards et alors ouais et voilà
c'était est-ce que vous aviez des pistes
sur le comment faire baisser le prix de
l'énergie de façon assez générale et la
dernière alors féminin puis on va
prendre le monsieur qui proteste
derrière le pilier comme ça ça féminin
ici là la
dame non non il une dame
oui bonjour vous aviez parlé un moment
des PME et de leur implantation dans le
territoire oui et je me pose la question
on a parlé également disons du prix de
l'immobilier on a l'aspect qualité de la
vie sur en région parisienne notamment
et est-ce que c'est pas une politique à
mener de réaménagement du territoire de
manière à développer les villes moyennes
et une meilleure qualité de la vie dans
ces
villes alors monsieur qui qui vous
exprimiez derrière le poteau
là-bas non
allez-y allez-y
voilà c'est un garçon allez-y
allez-y dit quelque
chose j'ai plusieurs choses à dire la
première ce sont des questions la
première comment conjugue le politique
et l'économique d'accord d'accord ok
pour vous c'est à vous que je m'adresse
d'ord
a la deuxème vous avez parler de taux de
change de taux d'intérêt de l'Europe de
beaucoup de choses oui
et ce que Baou a essayé de dire c'est
qu'en fait le politique tient le
l'économique tuprès ce que j'ai compris
non
d'accord maintenant je vais finir
d'accord
le il se trouve que si je suis venu ici
c'est qu'en 2007
euh avant et à marê je suis venu
soutenir Barou quand personne ne croyait
en
lui et alors
vous allez vous faire engueuler
là et en fait je connaissais parce que
je suis de la Martinique en fait il le
président du parti socialist je lui ai
demandé de vous rejoindre parce que je
je savais que le vent allait tourner et
ce soir je suis là et je me suis dit
pendant que tout le monde est dans la
rue pour combattre le mariage gay et je
me suis dit on en train de
discuter de politique de rau de choses
importantes et là je me suis dit ça
c'est pour la raison pour laquelle je
suis ici donc vous êtes content voilà
non c'est pas que ça j'étais en Irlande
il a parlé d'euro j'ai vécu le la crise
en Irlande quand on parle l'euro et ce
que j'ai compris c'est comment on parle
au peuple comment on parle aux
gens bien si on fait
l'économique tout à l'heure vous avez
posé la question quelle émission c'était
ce soir ou jamais
et d'ailleurs je même je va même vous
dire que
euh j'admire votre éloquence mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est qu'à un
moment à un moment donné il faut aussi
donner au peuple le doit il faut il faut
quelqu'un pour le soutenir et la
discussion qu'on vient d'avoir ce soir
entre l'économique entre les taux
d'échange que les personne ne comprend
entre le Doig
communautaire qui ne qui qui qui embrase
le doigt national et bien je vous dire
et je termine là-dessus il faut
quelqu'un qui a une voix et il semble
que votre voix en tout cas ces derniers
temps je vous ai pas entendu et je crois
que vous avez eu raison de ne pas vous
emêler dans ces histoires de mariage
Guer et que vous préoccupez de la vraie
vie la vraie politique ok merci beaucoup
bon ça ça ça ça sera plutôt votre partie
là ok donc vous étiez derrière le pilone
et derrière le pilier comme d'autres
étaient dans derrière le pilier de de
Notre-Dame
ils avent eu des illuminations
eu sur les sur les problèmes des marches
des entreprises les marches des
entreprises sont effectivement
extrêmement basses de l'ordre de 27 à 28
% de la valeur ajoutée et c'est un
chiffre que l'on n pas eu depuis 10 ans
bon alors ensuite est-ce qu'il y a de
l'argent ailleurs oui oui oui est-ce
qu'il y a a de l'argent caché oui oui
oui simplement il y a quelqu'un qui est
un économiste qui s'appelle La Fontaine
he vous rappelez qui avait dit essayer
de travailler de laborer votre votre
votre votre territoire vous trouverez
vous trouverez de l'argent par le
travail appelez ça donc je suis assez
favorable qu'il y ait des problèmes de
capitaux et et de
fiscalité que il soit étrange qu' a en
France en France à Espagne entre
parenthèses des billets 500 € euh qui
circulent et cetera et cetera tout ceci
ce sont effectivement des pousces au
crime que l'on n pas euh que l'on a des
problèmes de concurrence fiscale et
parfois d'excès fiscaux parce que nous
sommes dans excès fiscal ici que tout
ceci soit malencontreux grave je suis
d'accord simplement n'oubliez pas le
profit se fait par le travail et la
prise de risque pas par la découverte
d'argent à l'UBS et et et et tout
l'argent à
l'UBS ne suffira jamais à à dynamiser
l'économie ça n'est pas du transfert
c'est de l'énergie ça peut toujours
aider et fondamentalement ce qui va ce
qui va se passer ce qui va se passer
c'est que le message est assez clair ne
le faites pas et donc d'une certaine
manière tout ce qui se passe dans à
l'Espagne pas en Espagne avec
Enor dans les les grands duchers et
cetera et cetera tout ceci à mon avis va
être réduit et limité bon simplement
faisons bien attention à ça faisons
comprendre la nécessité du profit pour
l'investissement c'est ça mon histoire
et et et si on a des politiques
répressives par rapport au fait que les
gens gagnent de l'argent effectivement
ils essaieront de le de le sortir quoi
donc les marges des entreprises à mon
avis sont sont sont faibles et trop
faibles et c'est pour ça que que les
entreprises sont affaiblies par rapport
ceci renvoie un peu à la question que
vous que vous posiez sur les PME et les
territoires ce qui se passe c'est que et
ça vous le vivez hein l'union entre PME
et territoire n'a pas lieu quoi on a des
luttes de classes territoriales qui sont
fol furieuse j'étais une fois à pot et
il y avait un député Palois la région
quoi qui c'était mais bon faisons bien
attention on est dans dans des pays où
les gens se connaissent
ok où les gens se voient et et et donc
la PME la TPE c'est elle qui fera
l'emploi local et la façon dont elle
vivra avec l'IUT l'école d'ingénieur
l'université c'est ça qui fera son
développement et et son et son expansion
alors bien entendu il y a des grandes
innovations il y a des grandes
découvertes qui se fait mais mais mais
90 % du temps il y a des petites et
moyennes innovations il y a des petites
et moyennes choses qui faut font que
l'on vit mieux et que l'on vit mieux en
avançant par rapport à d'autres dans un
processus concurrentiel et les
territoires et les PME c'est-à-dire le
fait de travailler avec les IUT les
écoles de commerce les écoles
d'agriculture et autres tout à l'heure
vous parliez des stratégies stratégie
agricooles ça me paraît des trucs
extrêmement importants stratégie de
santé stratégie d'immobilier ce sont des
pistes qui nous permettent de nous
permettrai de nous développer simplement
il faut que les gens se parlent et les
territoires sont dans un coin et les
et les territoires politisés sont dans
un autre il se trouve que je suis prof
de faculté hein et j'étais dans une
banque il y a pas très très longtemps
enfin il y a quelques temps j'avais
invité à des enseignants du secondaire
de venir discuter avec moi et quelqu'un
me dit ils m'ont dit nous ne rencontrons
pas des acteurs
économiques je je lu dit j'ai pas
compris il me dit vous êtes un acteur
économique je je suis un être humain bon
a prori on peut rediscuter je suis
banquier bon fait je travaille il me dit
mais vous avez un bet mais sûr j'ai un B
je travaille voilà là où je suis je peux
vous raconter et donc l'idée est
vraiment très grave et et dans l'école à
tout niveau sur le fait que les
entreprises vivent et les TPE et cetera
et cetera tout ceci c'est un maillage à
à refaire et c'est ça qui est la vraie
source de la marche quo me semble-t-il
sur les problèmes de de
modernisation de de modernisation
bonheur temps de travail
j'ai rien contre le fait si vous voulez
que que vous
puisiez moduler le temps de travail
simplement historiquement pour si vous
voulez la croissance il faut de
l'énergie de l'énergie au sens de
l'énergie du travail de la prise de
risque du capital du temps de travail
c'est c'est c'est en tournant tout ça
que vous avez de la
croissance c'est et si vous n'avez pas
plus d'innovation
plus d'énergie plus de prise de risque
que les autres vous aurez moins de
croissance alors bien entendu on peut
faire le choix du style mesdames et
messieurs J'ai moins de croissance et je
vais faire
visiter le pays
profond voilà les Hautes Pyrénées
profondes et cetera et cetera c'est
c'est intéressant les grottes et cetera
et les ours
bon
simplement ce choixl est un choix
fondamentalement
égoïste parce que dans 5 ans dans 10 ans
et dans 20 ans vous avez tué le pays pas
vous en fait c'est un choix qui fabrique
à mon avis et et et on doit tout à
l'heure le problème de la dette le
problème du déficit c'est que c'est
fondamentalement un choix égoïste c'est
c'est-à-dire et on dit ça de manière
très sympa du style nos enfants bon on
tue le pays c'est pour ça qu'ils partent
d'ailleurs pourquoi ce que quand on
quand il dit pourquoi ils se tir tout
Simp un parce que les marges sont pas là
et puis deux ils veulent pas ils veulent
pas payer pour pour les dettes qu'on
leur laisse ils viendront nous voir ils
nous envont des mails il y a aucun
problème ils seront gentils avec
nousresond oui je pense qu'il faut que
vous rappeliez votre
correspondant
voilà attendez je je finis monsieur je
finis monsieur parce toute façon votre
question était au président
et et jusqu'à maintenant jusqu'à
maintenant lui c'est lui et moi c'est
moi
et je cite attz je finis je finis
monsieur et sur les problèmes de de de
très important si vous voulez de de de
temps de travail d'énergie il faut qu'il
y ait à mon avis l'idée que si on n pas
une espèce de sursaut productif et de
sursaut territorial et sursaut d'échange
on se sort pas d'affaair et le bonheur
s'ensuit pourquoi est-ce que les gens
sont pas contents du président et cetera
et cetera d'abord parce qu'ils ont pas
lu entièrement ce livre où il montrre
qu'il nous sauve mais euh
fondamentalement parce que vous avez un
taux de chômage quand vous avez des taux
de chômage de 20 % qu'est-ce que vous
faites ou des taux de chômage pour les
enfants pour les jeunes de de 25 quand
vous avez un taux de chômage de 40 % en
Espagne qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que vous avez du travail noir
qui se met en place c'est évident quand
vous êtes dans le Sud-Ouest vous avez
des des des des ouvriers agricoles pour
40 € par jour par jour hein bon donc et
alors bien entendu et à pot et et à ce
momentlà il travaille en lieu et place
des autres vous voyez bien que tous les
toutes et donc ça vous avez la
désespérance parce que j'ai pas compris
j'imagine pas que les espagnons sont
très contents de travailler comme ça et
j'imagine pas que les Palois sont très
contents d'être évincés ainsi donc d'une
certaine manière le bonheur d'une
certaine manière est dans une espèce de
de croissance partagée et et de et de et
de désir partagé d'évoluer je pense que
c'est plutôt ça alors et avec l'idée de
prendre des risques les grands travaux
j'ai rien contre le fait des grands
travaux simplement il faut qu'il fasse
de la croissance un collègue qui n'a pas
pu V dire qu'il s'appelle
Kees a fait des grands travaux et cetera
mais qu'est-ce que c'était lui les
grands travaux on est on est en
Angleterre les taux de change sont fixe
ma politique monétaire ne peut plus
marcher et donc qu'est-ce que je vais
faire je vais dire à quelqu'un de faire
des trous dans la pelouse je cite dans
la pelouse de la Banque centrale
anglaise de reboucher le trou de refaire
du trou de reboucher le trou de refaire
du trou de reboucher du trou de faire de
la demande et ça s'appelle la relance
par la demande très connu de nos amis
pour faire repartir l'importation et et
et dans la logique dans la logique
kénésienne de cet moment-là je je
développe de la demande je développe de
l'inflation un jour ou l'autre je
dévaluerai ma monnaie et un jour ou
l'autre avec mon mon inflation j'auraai
l'euthanasie des rentiers est-ce que
nous voulons ça pas moi est-ce que vous
voulez ça mais évidemment non donc les
grands travaux qui marchent ce sont des
travaux qui fondent la croissance et
qu'est-ce que c'est que les grands
travaux qui fondent la croissance
aujourd'hui c'est de l'innovation ce
sont les pôles de compétitivité c'est la
façon de fonctionner c'est pas forcément
des grandes routes et des grande voie
mais c'est peut-être des grands réseaux
à mettre en place à côté des universités
et cetera la forme des grands travaux
c'est pas forcément des btpsur je vous
AR
vous
répondre attendez le le attendez
monsieur dans la dans la discussion dans
la discussion monsieur dans la
discussion le silence est un élément
extrêmement important le respect
attendez mais qu'il est raison oui mais
dans la discussion et dans la dans la
communauté oui mais vous aussi un jour
et j'espère que vous laisserez autant de
autant de travaux que lui euh sur le
prix de
l'énergie nous devons avoir une
politique de de prix de l'énergie
par alors je pas moi le nucléaire
m'embête pas le gaz de schiste m'ennuie
pas et cetera et cetera bon ok mais les
produits et la réutilisation du méthan
agricole ne m'embête pas non plus et
donc ce qui se passe à l'heure actuelle
quand vous avez la politique la
stratégie énergétique de l'Allemagne
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils vont dire on a
arrêté le pétrole les grunen disent
c'est vachement sympa et qui va payer
les
Allemands pas les entreprises allemandes
les Allemands ils vont avoir un
doublement du prix de l'énergie tout
simplement parce que tout le monde est
dit d'accord vous voulez plus ça
d'accord vous allez voir et vous
allemand prez pour qu'on soit compétitif
un jour ou l'autre il va y avoir des
réactions de ce point de vue-là s bien
sûr et donc ils ont une stratégie qui à
mon avis est incompatible avec leur
propre croissance sur longue période
ensuite on dit on va mettre des
éoliennes et cetera et cetera d'accord
je t'en fous les éoliennes c'est quand
même une technologie complètement
ringarde en fait bon bon comme ça puis
vous mettez ça et ça ça travaille ça
travaille le tiers du temps et cetera
qu'est-ce que vous en faites il en faut
vous mais il faut fabriquer un un
ensemble d'éléments mais nous il se
trouve que l'on a un avantage qui qui
existe qui est un avantage nucléaire bon
voilà dans le livre il y a j'ai fait le
petit calcul moi-même c'est-à-dire que
sur 30 ans l'ensemble des résidus et
cetera et cetera ça fait un cube de 17 m
d'arête bon c'est beaucoup hein enfin
bon VO donc al c'est c'est
catastrophique il y a toute une série de
de verres qui s'engirceraient là-dessus
bon mais mais mais mais qu'est-ce que ça
implique en terme de croissance d'emploi
comment est-ce qu'on va pas trouver des
solutions alors je je n'ai pas dit
fabriquer des des centrales partout et
cetera et cetera je dis métaniser se
développer mais c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important étant entendu
que par exemple la Chine et autres vont
avoir besoin de ces de ces savoir-faire
de nouvelles technologies et si on peut
exporter nos savoirfire en terme
d'énergie c'est très bien mais si nous
ne voulons pas baisser le prix de
l'énergie je vois pas pourquoi d'abord
on demanderait au salariés de payer le
prix de l'énergie qui monterait et
pourquoi on naurait pas une politique
pluriénergétique qui nous permettrait de
sortir d'affaires je finis là-dessus
pour répondre après je vous laisse
laapéro raison sur euh les rapports
entre l'économie la morale et cetera et
cetera donc toute une série de choses
toutes simples et la politique oui le
politique pas la politique bien sûr
euh mais mais fondamentalement il y a le
le livre c'est c'est ça l'histoire vous
avez raison Madame on est on est un
grand pays virgule inquiet
euh on essaie d'attendre end
effectivement une sortie c'est pas
impossible qu'un jour il y ait une
espèce de sortie d'un grand monsieur ou
d'une grande dame qui nous aide et
cetera et cetera et qui Polaris les
anticipations et d'une certaine manière
il faut se préparer
aussi on sait quand même qu'il y a
quelque chose alors bien sûr c'est pas
forcément 90 % c'est peut-être 95 et
cetera mais enfin quand
même on en a fait beaucoup
bon on a il y a un pays un pays qui qui
est sousdéveloppé dans lequel ils ont 10
% de piip de moins que nous ils ont pas
de piip publique dépensent dans la
structure publique 10 % de PIB que nous
ce sont les Allemands est-ce qu'ils ont
ils ont pas d'autres Pitau plutôt ils
ont pas d'université plutôt ils ont ils
ont rien sur ça arrive quand même à
faire de l'efficacité publique OK et
c'est cette efficacité publique avec des
territoires et des PME c'est ça qui
fabrique des gens qui son sont plus
heureux le bonheur d'une certaine
manière ça vient du fait que l'on
discutera entre nous dans une situation
avec plus de croissance et plus
d'emploi merci à
vous je réponds en deux mots à la
question économie
politique
c'est le le n'est-ce pas quelle est la
resp
du
politique des politiques et du
responsable politique quel est son
travail c'est faire que son pays la
communauté dont il a la
charge
soit créative positive heureuse et que
dans chaque famille on a l'impression
que les enfants qu'on met au monde iront
mieux trouveront une vie meilleure que
celle que nous avons à l'heure actuelle
ou au moins aussi bonne c'est ça la
responsabilité un
jour très émouvant pour moi j'ai eu une
conversation la seule que j'ai eu de ma
vie
vraiment toutes les autres étaient
fausses la seule conversation vraie que
j'ai eu avec Jacques Chirac CIT pas
facile d'avoir une conversation vraie
avec Jacques Chirac parce
que considérer que la plupart des
personnes avec qui il parlait il parlait
pour qu'il soit dit qu'il avait parlé
avec elle pas pour échanger il mettait
le disque et puis et c'était un momentès
un peu dur de ma vie parce que j'avais
un enfant malade et et il a vu sur ma
figure que ça n'allait pas et on a eu
une conversation d'homme à homme de père
de famille à père de famille c'était
très bien et très émouvant et je en suis
reconnaissant tant d'années après et à
la fin de la conversation il m'a dit tu
veux qu'on parle politique une
seconde j'ai dit oui mais mais dit
qu'est-ce que tu nous emmerdes avec les
idées euh et j'ai dit il m'a dit la
politique c'est pas les idée je vais te
dire ce que c'est la politique on était
en temps de
cohabitation 2000
donc jepin matigon lui à l'élyisée je
vais te dire ce que c'est la politique
la politique c'est le premier ministre
ça sert à ce que ça ne se passe pas trop
mal en France il avait ce geste de la
main qui était le geste de ma mère quand
elle expliquait à ma femme ou aux
enfants comment elle faisait un
gâteau tu prends elle était pas amatrice
des proportions pesé
savez ça sert à ce que ça ne se passe
pas trop mal en France et le président
de la République ça sert à représenter
la France à l'étranger et je dis tu vois
c'est précisément sur ce point que nous
sommes en désaccord parce que moi je
crois lui aije dit que le Président de
la République ça sert à donner à un
peuple des raisons de
vivre d'avancer
d'entreprendre
de d'être
courageux de penser qu'il existe un
chemin
de se supporter les uns les autres de
s'entendre les uns les autres mon regret
sur le mariage gay c'est qu'on n pas
cherché à entendre l'autre on a créé un
affrontement parce qu'il était
politiquement rassembleur pour la gauche
et sans doute pour la droite aussi he on
n pas Robert a dit ça je suis
entièrement de cet
avis président de la République ça sert
à ça vous êtes politique c'est
d'ailleurs le rôle d'un maire dans un
village
pareil ça sert à à rassembler les gens
et à leur donner des raisons de se
mettre en marche de mettre un pied
devant
l'autre encore faut-il savoir dans
quelle direction et le problème
précisément aujourd'hui c'est que
personne n'est capable de dire dans
quelle direction on
marche même pas moi qui essaie de
comprendre d'assz près qui parle avec
qui il faut même pas moi on a un
problème parce qu'il y a une
contradiction que tout le monde voit
bien entre la majorité le Parti
socialiste et le gouvernement enfin non
la majorité du Parti socialiste est ce
qu'il faut faire pour la France il a une
contradiction entre le programme et les
promesses et les réalité tout quand même
se dit les gens sont les Français sont
pas complètement fous non mais je pense
qu' ils seraient prêt à entendre encore
faut-il qu'on leur parle et qu'on leur
dise une langue qui soit compréhensible
par tout le le monde et tous ces débats
qui consistent à remettre en question
par exemple l'idée que le surendettement
c'est quand même inquiétant pour un pays
alors je sais pas si la barrière est à
90 ou 85 ou 95 de toute façon 95 on y
est et ça on va y être bon alors tu vas
où ben tu vas au point où tout d'un coup
les gens vont dire quand même ils sont
très endettés hein et alors tous ceux
qui disent car il y en a surtout 1,2 %
1,5 % tous ceux qui disent mais la dette
on sera pas obligé de la rembourser vous
savez bien je dis ah ça c'est très bien
sauf si vous êtes obligé d'emprunter
tout les jours pour vivre parce que si
moi je vais voir mon
banquier beaucoup moins généreux à mon
endroit que au vôtre mais si je vois mon
banquier je lui dis écoutez vous m'avez
prêté 200000 € alors je viens vous dire
deux choses premièrement je vous les
rembourse
pas deuxièmement vous allez m'en prêter
200000 autres il peut survivre à la
première affirmation mais je suis sûr
qu'il n'acceptera pas la deuxième ben
c'est ça que nous sommes en train de
vivre nous sommes le seul pays européen
de notre gamme qui a un besoin vital
d'emprunter pour vivre je vais vous dire
des trucs tout bas l'Italie n'a pas
besoin d'emprunter pour
vivre si l'Italie se tourne vers ses
banquiers et lui dit écoutez ça
n'arrivera pas naturellement c'est une
théorie mais théoriquement il se tourne
vers les banquiers il dit écoutez
excusez-nous on vous remboursera pas
mais ils vont continuer à vivre nous pas
parce que pour payer les feuilles de
sécu pour payer les retraites pour payer
les fonctionnaires pour payer
l'investissement public on emprunte tous
les
jours j'entendais l'autre jour toutes
les idées qui tournent autour de on va
faire un grand emprunt auprès des
Français très bien l'épargne française
c'est 180 milliards on emprunte 178
milliards par an ça va durer combien
notre truc hein on par an hein en flux
comme le dit pas en stock hein mais en
flux on emprunte pour renouveler notre
dette 178 milliards par an qu'est-ce que
c'est ces trucs il y a évidemment que
des choses à faire c'est s'occuper de de
de l'énergie de la source de la volonté
du pays qui fait qu'on va recréer des
richesses et des emplois à partir
desquels nous pourrons bâtir nous
pourrons garder conserver développer le
modèle social qui est le nôtre si on n'a
pas cette volonté- làà et cette énergie
là on pourra avoir les belles théories
économiques on va dans le mur et moi je
souhaite que nous n'allions pas dans le
mur merci à
tous